que c'est beau alors comme ça tu as
commencé vous à chaque fois ça coûte
cher mais dedans je vois que vous
intéresser aux variétés alors comme je
suis en train de faire un petit sondage
sur la vie des femmes sur le cinéma est
ce que je peux vous demander votre avis
à vous madame
monopinion à mon opinion c'est que je
cinéma surtout de dix ans de la mesure
des grandes vedettes qui sont surtout
attirante par leur corps je dirais
spécial mattern comme corps ou alors
qu'elles font de choses
après ça va à mesure des tact comme par
exemple le disons de laon qui d'après
mme massé sociaux n'est que d'autres si
le sens bien sûr mais que lui fait quand
même des choses comme moi j'ai une
meilleure disent non à fin moi j'aime
beaucoup beaucoup ce qui fait quoi
dernière main dans les gitans c'était
très beau d'après moi encore bien alors
là je vais prolonger la vie d'une autre
personne que tu as qu'une autre
génération pour compléter ceux qui
s'engagent et madame s'il vous plaît
votre avis sur le cinéma
comment votre avis sur le cinéma sur le
cinéma le cinéma
payet lui paraît bien pour écouter sans
faille je m'adressais à quelqu'un dont
un modèle s'il vous plaît votre avis sur
le cinéma c'est pour un sondage le
cinéma c'est pas ton c'est l'évasion
mais j'ai ma formule qu'il aime bien que
personnel chef-d'oeuvre chez deux une
formule une part de génie au ccri on y
va on y va
les parents les enfants j'ai cinq
enfants je parlais pas chef-d'oeuvre pas
trace de génie on ignore on passe outre
vulgairement on s'en tape
bon très bien alors encore une autre
personne a que j'essaye de à fait dans
la rue s'il vous plaît je voudrais
simplement vous demander très rapidement
votre avis sur le cinéma mademoiselle au
cinéma je paye ivan 15 bars bientôt
vingt balles
moi je m'en fous pour moi c'est bon
moment que je flics pendant cinq heures
john farsi une toile
histoire de faire sauter la superbe
histoire de prendre mon pied
oui d'accord bon alors là oui oui bon
écouter alors là je vais quand même pour
conclure ce sondage
mais je me suis rendu spécialement à la
sortie du festival de bagneux où j'ai
rencontré la starlette arlette marlou et
je pense que c'est un avis qui vaut son
pesant d'or arlette que pensez vous du
cinéma
eh bien je crois je peux dire ça démarre
très fort pour moi je viens de tourner
un bout de sai on est en ligne avec la
femme
plus exactement avec le bras droit de
carlos ghosn au riz très très connue en
italie
c'est le même il m'a raconté d'ailleurs
il m'a reçu chez lui l'a enlevé la super
c'est pour tourner le rôle de la lionne
dans son prochain film qui va s'appeler
la lyon
cela dit il dit je suis avec mon
personnage mais on m'a souvent dit que
j'avais tout à fait un physique de
l'yonne c'est pourquoi je crois je peux
dire ça démarre très fort pour moi j'ai
intégré dans mon moteur